in the 20 years since 9 11 the u.s has
spent over 2 trillion dollars on the war
in afghanistan that's 300 million
dollars per day
every day for two decades
or 50 000 for every person in
afghanistan's population of 40 million
you could also look at it this way
america has spent more trying to keep
the taliban at bay than the net worths
of jeff bezos elon musk
bill gates and the 30 richest
billionaires in america all put together
800 billion dollars was allocated to
direct war fighting costs
85 billion dollars was spent to train
the afghan military which ended up
folding and surrendering in the weeks
since the pentagon closed bagram air
force base in july this effectively
removed american air support against the
taliban
750 million dollars a year was allocated
to salaries for afghan soldiers and then
there's the human cost
47 000 afghan civilians dead
69 000 afghan security forces over 3 500
coalition troops two thousand five
hundred of them us military personnel
four thousand u.s contractors
figures for dead opposition fighters are
estimated at around fifty one thousand
the cost so far to care for the twenty
thousand americans wounded in the
conflict has been about 300 billion
dollars with another half trillion or so
expected to come
the united states financed the war with
borrowed money researchers at brown
university estimate more than 500
billion dollars in interest has already
been paid
they think that by 2050 the cost of
interest alone on our afghan war debt
could reach 6.5 trillion dollars that
equals about 20 thousand dollars for
every us citizen
[Music]
so
okay
[Music]
all right ladies and gentlemen wow yeah
that's a lot of money that's a lot of
cheeses somebody told me a long time ago
that's a lot of cheese man 300 million
dollars a day and that's only
that's for 2 million that's for 2
trillion
2 trillion for the last 20 years
and we are almost 30 trillion dollars in
debt think about that okay think about
that
my mind can't even wrap it up for for
people watching this show around the
world we are in america we're americans
we love america and we're very patriotic
and i want to tell you right now
this is not what americans are about
we are not about this even though
they've been spending this money for the
last 20 years but we honestly aren't
about it no and no hey that's not us we
don't have to approve they are
right they are not not us right
the uh the what congress has done
in the name of the american people
uh is atrocious
it's atrocious the way that they have
spent money we did not have
and we did not well i mean
i can tell you that we didn't approve it
but
we
a lot of americans voted these people in
and these and the people took advantage
of the american people in
their trust and kept on spending and
spending money that we didn't we didn't
we didn't tell them to go into
afghanistan to take over after russia
left and go into afghanistan for 20
years
we didn't ask them to do that nope we
didn't we didn't ask him to
uh um uh
to uh nation build all around
i mean the the best president i know
that has
taken that has taken the idea of what
america's wanted
over the over the last 20 years is
probably trump is when he said america
first america wants to be treated or
look
or uh
america wants
to be
fixed first if we fix our problems first
if we fix our problems our homeless
uh and and i know there's probably
always gonna be homeless but there's a
big large amount of homeless our
veterans our kids our our education
system our roads our bridges if we fix
all of that first
and if somebody comes and says can y'all
help
okay well i'll tell you what
give us a point paper on it give us the
white paper on it and
let us re read and do the math on it see
if it helps us any what's in it for us
we lost that what's in it for us right
we've lost that in america
trump said we should have gone and taken
the oil in saudi arabia trump said we
should have taken the oil everybody
screamed you're taking the oil no we
didn't get the oil we should have taken
the oil afghanistan we should have taken
the mineral rights why because the
taliban has just now walked up upon one
trillion dollars worth of federal rights
and guess who's gonna get it china
thank you to the bushes thank you to the
clintons thank you to obama and now
obama part two
damn you guys
oh my god so shout out to my uh barbara
penny she uh greatest fate there ever
was on the west side of cincinnati penny
loyal listener love you babe
incredible
the owl ain't gonna see them see that's
why i'm wearing the hat because my
barbara has been in albania
since last month let's go random so yeah
she's supposed to be back yeah right now
that's her home yeah
well i actually went to the hair salon
yesterday too so thank you olivia and
she's going on maternity leave so
kind of how do we just start talking
about haircuts man i know that's true
what is the headline today
we had to segue into like a happiness
thing here okay
well i uh i ain't happy because i've
been missing my barber
i've i've been missing it she's supposed
to be back next week so
you know i'll take care of that okay uh
again ladies and gentlemen uh
oh wait wait i like this chat right now
i want y'all to i want you to um i want
to read something to y'all
i just got it this morning okay i just
got it this morning and i sent out my
response it was kind of nasty response
but
whatever um it was called
you're so dumb
okay
okay give it context who's this from
yeah i don't know this is from ken
gardanya that's right i called your name
out because you emailed me on my website
so i'm like
okay um only a foolish chicken hawk
could possibly oh i'm sorry dear wayne
only a foolish chicken heart could
possibly fall mr biden
for ceasing our presence in afghanistan
as mr biden concluded as painful as it
is no amount of blood or the blood and
guts of more u.s service personnel
would change the outcome today
tomorrow or next year as the past 20
years have demonstrated
concrete
consequently
i question your motives for such a
irresponsible piece of journalism it is
possible but i assume not probable that
you are just plain stupid
so what are the real
reasons for your position do you derive
monetary gain for the continuation of
the charade
or possibly your conscience has you
feeling guilty about the precarious
position of the afghan folks who
assisted our cause
what exactly is the root cause of your
absolutely outrageous position on this
matter in closing sir the afghan people
have spoken very clearly in the past
they don't want us there or they
wouldn't still be fighting the taliban
for every square inch of their country
if they won't fight why should we
my response is stupid idiot i didn't
i said that i mean i said that
we were going to be leaving
sooner or later
the taliban was going to take over when
we left every person knows this
but
biden as president of the united states
this idiot just like you idiot
left americans over there
right he's the leader of the country
he took his truth and left
americans civilians
over there
so are you trying to say that it's not
the fact that he left it's the way that
he left it's the way he left
it's the way he left
there
fro
from what i'm hearing
people told him don't do it
right even
i'm hearing people told him don't do it
and he did it anyway now
then we have to ask who told him to do
it i know somebody had to have told him
to do this okay
he doesn't have the cognitive abilities
even millie said please let me leave
2500 troops in even millie critical race
theory millie is that how you say his
name even even he said
he had a general yeah
he's totally 2500. i'm telling you it's
obama and then
fiasco and then on top of that
biden's u.n ambassador said that look at
this with the people literally hanging
on to the plane preparations weren't
made yeah
uh gail absolutely preparations were
made we did contingency planning but
none of us
can appreciate what happens when the end
of a civil war takes place and and the
victors
enter the city
appreciate appreciate the end of a civil
war
the victors yeah and the victors
airplane fans are talking about the same
country is she even on the same page
she's not even in the same world okay
oh my god when i heard that
and that's biden's you in ambassador no
that's you an ambassador aren't they
asking aren't they asking the ewing to
pick up the strings pick up the the
pieces
i thought i was reading an article where
they're asking the u.n to step in and
they'll pick up the pieces yeah
i saw that i i saw that this morning i
was like wait a minute you're
biden
asked the taliban to help
yeah that's right
[Music]
to evacuate
and
and from what we're seeing the taliban
are firing
on the crowds
all right
buying you're saying hey
could you help us uh get some of those
chevys out yeah sure wait yeah
here you can have them now they're
easier to transport you just stack them
oh my god
stacking my passengers this is biden's
blame game he's lost the independent
vote he's lost democrats that were
veterans he's lost them
uh and now we're hearing that the afghan
people were protesting and they wanted
their national flag
to be hanging in the streets but instead
the taliban wants their terrorist flag
so afghan protesters
decided to take down the terrorist flag
and hang the
afghan the national flag and when you
said everybody got they were shooting in
to the crowd because of it right yeah um
they were shooting people at well they
were shooting around the airport
um planes were taken off without people
on it because people couldn't get on it
uh and then they were shooting at the
people in the streets
so to put in perspective the afghan
protester protesters showed more bravery
and more guts
than what joe biden did joe biden coward
and the afghan people are standing out
there trying to wave their flag and
getting shot up by the taliban that just
puts it in perspective and you can't
blame the pilots for those of you out
there like why would pilots leave with
no people on her why would they this or
why would they that i'm gonna tell you
right now air force pilots are just well
i say they're people like you and me but
they're a little bit different anyways
but they're still human beings right and
when somebody's firing upon you and just
keep this in perspective most pows are
air force members because we don't carry
weapons we just don't have guns they
overrun the air brakes and they put us
all in pow caps uh so if if you're a
pilot
i'm the hell up out of here i'm in an
aircraft
i'm out bye i know i'm not dying for
this
and you said that joe is depending on
the taliban
and the ukraine and the u.s
joe can't even depend on his bladder to
get him through the day
to save americans isn't that kind of an
oxymoron the taliban saving americans
i mean the last time i looked they
killed 2 977 of them on 9 11. do we all
just forget that it's like asking a drug
dealer down the street to help me get
these guys cleaned up
people look it really is and there's
memes all over social media right now
like this mom is holding her daughter's
face to look at something and she's like
shivering she don't want to look at it
that's the people that voted for joe i
know you don't want to look at what's
going on it's not trump it's not
anything else it is this administration
you voted for
accept it understand it and realize we
knew this
yeah
did we not did we not know that joe
biden president united states was a
horrendously horrible beyond
comprehensive idea it was a bad idea
just back beyond bad
we told that
we got um
ladies and gentlemen thanks for watching
leah bella brian smith wayne dupree
wayne the pre-show kind of kind of late
into that but i i just want to let
everybody know
this is not i mean america that we
deserve a whole lot
better
than this administration now yeah we've
been making fun of it and we've been
calling out a whole lot of stuff for the
last seven months but what
biden did this is
this ep this failure is of epic
proportions this is not i mean again i
don't know
i don't know any president in my
lifetime in my lifetime
that has left um civilians
uncovered
in a hostile
land
left them uncovered and then had to send
troops back in
i mean the world
when we say the world is laughing
it's more than that
the world
our enemies
are now saying
america is weak
and we can do anything we want to do
because
the the leadership that is over there
they don't know what they're doing
they aren't up on anything
uh
and
the people are against the leadership
so we can play them against
each other
we can play off of this
facebook facebook is um
removing some of the taliban videos but
twitter is allowing the videos to just
stay up there as long as the guy don't
talk violence
you know and yesterday we say it oh yeah
the taliban's gonna come oh women yep
come on in everything's fine
we're all family you know whatever and
then you see the pictures of people
being shot and stuff the next day
i don't understand why all those afghan
men
were on the plane when where did but why
didn't they pick the americans first
that's what my question is what what
happened what breakdown was that there
to say okay let's load up these 300 000
i don't know how many afghan men onto a
plane and ship them to ohio and florida
and the uk where's all the americans
what exactly went down that they messed
it up that bad well according to the
administration they're in the queue
they're in the queue if you look at some
of the video footage some of the
pictures of the tarmac at the airport
it's like three trump rallies all put
together like everybody's there
everybody's and everybody's standing
around and there's just no way to get
out
it's a logistical nightmare it truly is
it is it is and
i'm sorry guys it's an impeachment
offense it really is i mean i know
everybody laughs at that but this is
something he could be impeached for
right absolutely not right and i heard a
whole lot of people uh i heard martin
levin mike mcmahon was talking about
that this morning this is an impeachable
offense it is i mean if the great one
says it i i believe it yeah i mean i'm
going to teach for a phone call
right a perfectly good one
right
no uh i mean i i don't know ladies and
gentlemen uh you you know you you're
watching you're watching this go down
let me let me tell you uh joe
scarborough who uh
who was once a republican i don't know
what he is now had a woman die in his
office and when he was a
politician just say nobody knows what
happened that just she was dead of
course not yeah
said he flipped democrat i i don't know
i don't know right after that yeah yeah
i've been saying that for years but no
um
he came out and said something this
morning and i mean
we knew we knew camilla harris had a
problem
uh before all this was going on but that
the dems weren't happy with her and a
lot of things that she was saying as a
matter of fact they have even had a
dinner and trying to fix certain things
um
joe scarborough
came out this morning and said damn job
in trouble let's talk about uh the mess
right now that i think the democrats are
facing uh and it's so early i really we
have a year and a half until the
election
uh but
uh
if democrats want to know what they're
going to be facing
let's talk about it right now because if
i were a republican running
i would say democrats can't protect us
across the world
democrats can't protect our street
and democrats can't protect us at the
border
there is we don't talk about it enough
there is a massive
border crisis on the southern border
right now
uh and if democrats don't want to talk
about it that's fine
uh it will find them uh over the next uh
16 months uh politically uh and then
there's this chaos in afghanistan
and we've talked about crime uh which of
course i had people telling me for a
year
oh it's just an exaggeration law and
order racist bigoted whatever eric adams
runs on
protecting streets and police reform
he wins the bronx
he wins queens
he wins well staten island uh and he
wins brooklyn he wins everything except
for the the the sort of wealthier parts
of manhattan
democrats have to understand this is
coming and i don't know where mission
control is on the democratic side
but somebody donny needs to get that
and they need to start responding
if i was president trump if i was
president trump
and i know him and joe and mika were
friends a long time ago but if i was
president of trump
i wouldn't say another got-during word
about cheating in 2020 and i would use
everything that joe
scarborough just said just while ago
and you would get elected in a super
gigantic
57 state landslide in 2014
right they said if there was a flash
election right now that trump would win
well yeah all 57
37.
57 57 states would would vote for
president trump if president trump got
up there and said the same thing the
joke y'all can't protect us overseas you
can't protect us on our streets you
can't protect us on our borders ladies
and gentlemen give me back the seat let
me put this country back on the right
track like i said i was going to do it
in the first place let's get this
country moving let's get this economy
moving and let's get these uh uh
amateurs out of the white house let's
get them out of the congress because we
all know
that democrats are going to lose in
2022. it's good i mean it was going to
happen anyway
all this is just
icing on the cake yeah well yeah i said
undertaker's scraps that come from the
table you know this is this is just
piling up for the dems uh but
trump
you want to win in 24 2024 you you want
a superior lands you want to be
president of the universal galactic
conference say what joe biden just yeah
don't talk about yourself trump talk
about joe talk about his failures we
know who you are we know what you've
done good we know what you can do talk
about joe talk about that southern
border because that's what the border's
not going to
but the southern border story with these
variants coming over and all these
people coming over they're now saying
that 70 of them are testing positive for
coven this story is going to get ugly
and i'm not one for identity politics i
really am not and i push back really
hard on those things but i'm gonna be
honest with you uh trump
give uh christy a call i think she's
good to go for vp
uh i'd like to see christy go head to
head toto kamala christie
no
kristen no
go ahead a lot of the republicans like
you anymore
here i am going like this because i'm
wondering why you were agreeing so i'm
like i know
why you know what's going no i'm not no
i'm not because currently right now your
vp the vp of the united states of
america kamala who is m.i.a we've all
said it we she's not out she's not
talking about this she's nowhere to be
found uh apparently inside information
says that they they approached her
sunday because joe was not in
a capacity
capacity
give a source for that too because i saw
that too but then i but then i saw
um
larry
no elder um no he's not curly
no
he's a he's a boy
he's become voice larry o'connor larry
o'connor
who has been a
conservative
strategic voice in washington d.c for
years he said that uh she was the last
person in the room or claimed that he
was the last person
i'll stick my neck out there
because if it if it looks like it's
possible
yeah i did i'm saying right now that it
is so highly possible
that they asked camilla because joe
couldn't do it joe wasn't there on
sunday he barely was there on was he
there on monday was it tuesday
i think he came back on monday left
monday night and then he came back this
morning at 9 00 a.m right so so there's
a horrendous situation going on with joe
even speaking about this to tap the vp
immediately hey joe's down joe's down
we're medicating them well he'd be good
to go
speak
if i was her
i i can only imagine if that really went
down she would have said uh
hell no
this is on you joker i want another
mistake
i don't know i mean
i think that ben carson would be a
better choice than chrissy known
christine oh yeah i love love ben carson
we interviewed ben carson yeah i think
he speaks well and i think since there's
covid he's a doctor i don't i don't know
i mean there's a correlation there
whether he's a doctor he's an eye doctor
an ear doctor doctor no he's a he's a
brain doctor for the babies these
surgery
when women are pregnant he goes and does
brain surgery when they're pregnant okay
you have to be a very smart man to do
that
i think that we need
i think he wins if he puts ben carson as
his vice president i'd love to see that
and i'm fluid just for everybody
watching oh brian you're jumping all
around
when it comes to vp i'm pretty fluid i
really am yeah i really truly believe
that ben carson is the answer i i think
that you know people play identity
politics i think that he goes up well
against kamala i think that she cannot
hurt him in any way or he will look
uh she'll make him look like a uh like
she's picking on him
it's not a mike pence remember when she
went up um
on stage with mike pence and she
attacked mike pence and mike pence just
kind of looked like a smart like a smart
aleck with her uh but i think that he
gives off this nice spoken talk where
she he would almost make kamala look
crazy
and then he would be able to come out
and explain
like you know how trump would talk
normal like he wouldn't use all these
fluff words like obama used right
remember obama would use all these big
words yeah like you can understand trump
when trump speaks yeah you can
understand it i think what happens is
when trump speaks he's very gruff this
is how it is this is how it's going to
be and this is what we're going to do i
think ben carson will would be able to
come out and say okay america
now for you democrats and liberals this
is what he's saying he's not saying to
put bleach into people they actually use
a disinfectant that you can ingest you
can swallow a light bulb uh there are
theories uh there are actual uv light in
the be light in the lungs that help
treat the lungs so before we before we
jump on it let's just go ahead and talk
about this so i would like ben carson to
run with him
i think that it's an instant win so
maybe we should get a hold of ben
carson's people get ben carson on here
and let's do a little talking about it
everybody in the chat agrees for the
first time ever brian
i see the the chat room agreeing
they like ben carson yeah he's brilliant
and he would be great right now we need
somebody softer we don't need somebody
hard-hitting right now we've got to
unite
and i thought that when he picked pants
i thought that that could have been a
soft saw
i'll be honest with you when he
originally picked pants i said oh damn
because he's indiana and i know i'm
right here in ohio i'm we're right next
to indiana i i've got family live there
it's just
it's it's that he's been in it too long
he's been there too long and he knows
too many people and we come to find out
that was all true pence made it look
like
like his goal was to make her look like
an amateur and he did
but it didn't come off well like you
didn't it wasn't a good look that's not
your fault never came off well i've
never liked pence from the beginning i
100 agree with you brian it didn't come
off well and um pence didn't have
really he didn't have backbone you can
you can take you can keep the p on his
name and erase the rest of his name and
add a ussy because that's how i feel
about him and
he but carson on the other hand he's
very very calm he's very
spoken
plain spoken and if you try and ruffle
his feathers i don't think the man has
feathers to be ruffled i really don't
i've seen people go at him when he was
hud secretary and and it it it didn't
work out it didn't fail he did well
right who's that yes
pence uh not pence uh ben carson
everybody in the chat loves ben carson
and wants him to run with drum
and i think it's a great idea you know
what i watched i watched a video i don't
know if y'all said this are we still
here
yeah no
oh bro's froze rosa
that's all right yeah
i wa i watched a video
when it was the gop
you might want to take yourself off come
back on we're back
take yourself off and come back on
can you see us
yep
okay you're frozen
there you go there you go um i was
watching a video where was the gop
uh
debate
yes
and
ben carson was supposed to be called
okay
but they called another republican
senator
so ben carson was standing
in the in the walkway
when it was him
then they caught another republican
senator and then
they told donald trump that it was his
turn
but he didn't call donald trump
they called jeb bush
okay so
trump and carson were standing
how wonderful
together in the back
and then they said they said um
uh
these are your
nominee uh candidates for the republican
candidate or for the republican
nomination
oh and we also have ben carson and
donald trump too come on out
yeah yeah um
i think we should have him back on and
ask him if he's going to ask trump
for the vp come on let's let's have him
on he loves you you know ben love jail
come on
let's check out check out check out um
what this democrat um
this democrat rep said about the
american embassy the thought that the
american embassy there is going to be
occupied by the taliban on 9 11
2021 the 20th anniversary what emotions
go through your mind when you hear that
it's a building
you know it's a building
um
i i let's let's point out by the way
we've still got about 6 000 troops on
the ground at kabul international
airport and uh hoping every one of them
comes home safe but their mission is
important they got to stay there until
we get all american personnel out safely
that's their job and i know that they're
proud to be doing it right now at the
same time also trying to get as many of
our afghan partners out as possible
so i think we got to
you know stick together as a country uh
and be pulling for them and making sure
that they've got everything they need
and know that we're behind them as they
carry out that important mission but uh
i don't feel uh strong emotions about
the embassy
wait a minute the embassy is just a
building is that what he said okay you
know what then you know what then the
capital was just a building the capitol
was just a building brian brian i'm
gonna i'm only gonna play the first
couple seconds of it i want you to hear
what this democrat rep said about the
u.n embassy
in afghanistan the thought that the
american embassy there is going to be
occupied by the taliban on 9 11
2021 the 20th anniversary what emotions
go through your mind when you hear that
um it's a building
you know it's a building
um
i i let's let's point out by the way
we've still got about 6 000 troops on
the ground at kabul international
airport and uh hoping every one of them
comes home safe but their mission is
important they got to stay there until
we get all american personnel out safely
that's their job and i know
it's not a building for those of you who
don't know
around the world for those who don't
know wherever we have an embassy in
somebody's country that is technically
our land it's american land when you
step foot on our embassy in france
you're in the united states
in russia wherever our embers if you get
your foot on that you are in america you
technically are in america it's not a
building
it's our land
what guy
i'm surprised that
he didn't know i mean no no no actually
i'm not because i've said many times
that the people in congress are stupid
they don't know what the constitution
they don't read they don't know anything
but for him not to know it's not just a
building
once you
that's why people run to get onto get on
the property if you're on the piece of
land
you have safety you don't even have to
be in the building it's i mean if you're
on that lane go ahead leah he knows that
he just wants to say that because then
it
undervalues the issue he's a democrat
that's what they do it's sophistry at
its finest it's just a building
he knows damn well that it's not just a
building but he knows if he says it like
hitler said if you tell a lie tell it
good and tell it a lot right
make it huge because people are going to
be like wow so then were the world trade
centers just building such a big lie why
would he lie about that well he's not if
it's just a building then that's rewind
to
september 11th and you can go into the
world trade centers if they're just
buildings
okay buddy i wonder who that was
you know um y'all talked about um you
know i talked about ben carson while i
was going i still think that uh
the south carolina governor is a whole
lot stronger than christie gnome ever
will be okay
right
yo i'm with you okay
he's made a huge splash here recently i
love him yeah yeah he loves her but look
carson and donald trump were outcasts
from the republicans
in 2016. right and if y'all don't
believe me
that video i was talking about watch
this welcome back to cbsn and our
continuing coverage of the republican
debate well it wasn't all heated
exchanges during tonight's event in fact
the debate actually started with a bit
of an awkward moment take a look
so let's welcome the candidates for the
republican nomination for president new
jersey governor chris christie
texas senator ted cruz
businessman donald trump
florida senator marco rubio
former florida governor jeb bush
ladies and gentlemen the republican
candidates
and dr ben carson please come out on the
stage he's standing there as well dr
carson
and donald trump
can i introduce you to someone
here yes yes
that's why i love you
that moment is why i loved him
crazy you know that's why we voted for
him is because of that stuff
they call both their names
but the person i mean
you listen to it they call both both
their names but the person that was
telling them to go to the podium never
told them to go to the podium
that's why they look confused where the
other people didn't look confused other
people just went
go ahead go but for carson and charm
that's why you know that's why
the only person that um trump put in his
cabinet was was um carson right when i
also saw that where trump i felt that
trump saw that ben missed the
opportunity he's like you know what
i'm going to stay here with ben
screw y'all
y'all a bunch of bums
ben was kind enough did you guys miss
that ben they told ben go ahead and go
but ben turned around was like wait no
they just announced this guy's name i'm
going to let him go out of respect
and then then ben let another guy go so
ben kind of knew but at that point he
was being respectful isn't it weird
though how they both ended up together i
think that was appropriate
don't forget about ted cruz cheating on
ben too don't forget about ted cruz now
he cheated ben out on on iowa
i don't forget that one ted that hurt
him really bad though
dirty dog that hurt crews really bad
ladies and gentlemen we're gonna rain
the pre-show and uh one of our sponsors
is
uh my pill we haven't did my pillow
right now no cause somebody was asking
are we getting a pajama party at the end
of the month and i didn't answer it yet
because it wasn't time yet
heated news today
let's rest up
yo yeah crazy yes i had an incredible
sleep last night just want to say
incredible sleep there's nothing in the
world like a my pillow mattress if
you're in the market for a mattress
adjustable beds regular beds everything
you ever wanted the three inch pillow
topper and the my pillows you get it
stiff you get fluffy
it it's like no pillow ever it is the
most unique pillow out there it's
incredible
i am 100
the behind the mattress topper if you
i mean honestly you need to get this
if you don't get it this weekend and you
don't get it before thanksgiving you
need to get it before christmas i'm not
playing uh you look at your bed
look i mean if you have coils in your
bat and and you have back issues then
this foam
uh mattress topper is what you want
mickey says that she's waiting on her
topper and sheets this topper is what
they have two inch they have three inch
it also comes with two free
uh my pillow pillows
so this is a great two for warner right
here but i mean i mean it's awesome i i
love it i've had my topper for almost a
year now yeah you can't even okay do you
know how with a bed there becomes
indentations where you sleep yeah
right you don't get indentations on this
i don't know why i don't know if it's
magic i don't know what mike lindell has
created down there in my pillow but it's
honestly like magic because there's no
indentations where i sleep
uh and i find that fascinating so it's
like the mattress topper that keeps on
giving because
it just it's ref it's always refreshed
every day i don't know how they do it
it's like it's rejuvenating itself
that's right that's right and and look
they're they're having a sale right now
on these go anywhere my pillows um you
can use it on your couch your recliner
you can use it in your car when you're
waiting on somebody and um to get off
work and they're they said to show up at
six o'clock and they don't get off until
6 45 and you out there waiting
you can
take them
[Laughter]
did you did you um hear how how hard i
said it waiting for so long
uh these buildings are here forever
why do you keep doing this
i had this article i had to write on
wayne debris.com and i'm sitting out
here in this car
is about to die i i have used that i
have used that many times
um
so uh yeah um order now
1-800-544-8939 or call 1-800-308
now you can use the code when on
everything on the website you will get
tremendous savings
up to about 66 off on many
things that are on the website using the
code however if you click on my the my
the radio specials
uh button
on the my pillar website then you will
see
uh specials tailored for this show so uh
special special um
yeah
thank you kathy kathy said
kathy said that you guys uh give such a
great show because you get a good
night's sleep thank you yeah yeah
and attention to the ladies christy
becky kathy laura nichola uh who am i
forgetting i know i'm forgetting a
couple top fans uh
but anyways
get yourself the robe and blush
in the slippers and blush it's so cute
i'm gonna wear it on the show one day at
least show it off for you guys the blush
slippers and the blush
uh robe amazing just wait
just wait
um
the former afghan president
he pulled a batista
he pulled a batista i don't even feel
sorry for you no more i mean you know if
i didn't know at first i was like oh man
they kicked him over i mean he ran out
of his country you know and he's running
to safety
jesus christ
160 million dollars dude
169 million dollars he look he
he stuffed it in his helicopter right
helicopter's full who sings that song
and he's in dubai
oh yeah
under asylum
living the dream
the greatest place ever to be a wealthy
multi-millionaire
and decide to be islamic if you want you
if you will you know and to be part of
that same cloth that being i mean you
got it all
you want for nothing in dubai
good god the same thing batista did in
cuba he rolled out on new year's eve
loaded his aircraft 300 million dollars
with the money and flew out
and he doesn't have to pay an american
taxes off that 163 million he just took
an american money that we had to pay
taxes for think of that jumbo mumble
our munitions our munitions our m16s our
humvees all of our equipment
taliban has it how about that he took
four cars and a helicopter
four
must be an expensive cars more cars and
a helicopter
let me tell you something that's a
hollywood movie
already
you could do yeah that's crazy
i mean i mean and
he had to be planted like that was a
contingency plan thing right there it's
like if this ever go down
that had those cars have to be ready
helicopter has to be on the helipad we
got to be ready to go if this ever goes
down
uh we're gonna bring amanda back on we
need to bring amanda back on man hey
this movie i changed up my script i got
a treatment here for you check this one
out it's done directing for a little bit
but yeah
please
uh
leah says something about the 25th
amendment uh rick scott is talking well
no no actually you said something about
impeachment both of y'all said somebody
imagine well um rick scott is talking
about invoking the 25th amendment now
here's the thing let's think about that
uh republicans and democrats are both
both sides right are two two sides of
the same coin
um they are not original
they pick off each other
republicans that do have more ideas
though i ain't gonna lie about that
republican had more ideas for the
country democrats steal the ideas gut it
and then just fill it with money and
things never get fixed
or at least that's how i look at the way
things are but uh rick scott is talking
about invoking the 25th amendment rick
scott
i know you're a republican and i
understand
what you mean by the 25th amendment
but you can only do this thing in secret
the 25th amendment thing is supposed to
be done in secret
and it's supposed to be done
from
a number of personnel in congress
they're supposed to come together and
they're supposed to have the vice
president
um
included
that's why
it has to be the white house yeah it has
to be the white house doctor it has to
be the vice president rick scott he can
be a megaphone all he wants but the
problem is the gop has become the little
boy that's cried wolf uh because
mccarthy just stated there should be a
probe into how joe handled afghanistan
well you know what you can stick your
probe where the sun don't shine because
every time there's a probe or there's a
committee it dies in committee it's like
vegas what goes in vegas what's what
what happens in vegas stays in vegas
well what happens in committee stays in
committee nothing ever gets done so take
your probe
stick it right so section 4 the 25th
amendment has never been used but
considered four times
uh they were nervous when reagan was
shot
really nervous they were shocked they
were they said they said that bullying i
remember
if it was just us i mean
by the grace of god yeah if it was just
a hair the wrong way and we didn't know
it that's the thing nobody didn't know
it nobody knew how bad it was they were
like oh you know it was a graze but
um
when
they were saying that they couldn't find
george w i mean
george h bush couldn't find him
and then
haye got on there
and he messed up his entire career for
intensive purposes i am in charge
that's what he said i am in charge no
you're not
i mean
the media went after him big time and
then
he resigned later on after that but
yeah um
but no uh yeah reagan reagan reagan was
almost
he almost died they said reagan joked
around with the surgeons when he was
they were getting ready to go under
that's what they said yeah that's just a
crazy i can tell you the 25th
amendment's not gonna happen with joe
they're gonna have to pull his cold dead
body out from the oval office do you
think so far from it do you think though
because i mean if the democrats said
that they want to do this
and they tap the republicans said hey
guys we're gonna do this you jump on
board republicans be like yeah let's do
it but obama will step in and say no
because right do you think that i mean
because you need the democrats to invoke
it don't don't the republicans can't do
this right you need the republican you
need the democrats to invoke this would
it be a good idea for democrats to do
that and how could they do that i mean
y'all put him in there they take him out
they just don't work
now
brian you're right i mean the democrats
would have to come to the conclusion
right now nancy pelosi is not wanting to
come to any conclusion about getting joe
biden out office i mean
she is defending him like he has some
honor and
probably does
i mean they need to 20 can we can we do
can we do two 25th amendments just a
50th amendment on both of them
yeah
they save taxpayer money and paperwork
i don't know i mean
is um is strict nine expensive these
days
no it's pretty cheap
oh no
hey did you know hemlock
hemlock's a real thing
and you could buy that
you could buy hemlock and make a tea
don't do it
don't do it don't do it what socrates
did it
what's that powder
what's that powder that um
they're all deadly i literally named all
deadly powders
i mean i just i've got a little yeah
look you got a little
just depends on the situation that hangs
no either why do i know all of this i
know
all those damn documentaries you'll be
watching that's why
um
id channel it's a oh yeah
don't even get me started on that one
did you know check love after lockup huh
i found out that cherry pits
have cyanide in them
if you eat cherry pits they'll kill you
what you know i ground them up in a
shake because i didn't realize i didn't
take them out oh i drank the whole day i
had six of them i drank the whole damn
thing ryan when did you do this
live
four or five days ago
yeah there can be the leg reaction bud
just say it
cherry pitch cherry pits don't you don't
eat them and don't do it i had no idea
this can't be true
here lies brian paul smith oh my god
he lived like a dog he died like a dog
undertaker
claiming about it
i was looking at seeds and and i got
this new blender and i'm just like so
stoked about making stuff
and
one cherry pits like why not blend a
fruit smoothie of kiwi and strawberries
and apples why not just go and get
poisonous mushrooms dude just i mean
just i don't know what you do
from there
hold on i'm not but but i don't like
cherry lisa i don't look
i don't look at cherry pits and be like
damn you look scrumptious
no no no you're like no i'm not your
go-to no you're just in the people and
you're like i know what cherry picks
it's this incredible blender i got that
makes everything into dust
flexi but
you drink
glasses of cherry pits and then found
out
yeah i did six of them in my my smoothie
yeah and then i was reading today or
yesterday i was reading from my wife i
was like oh see seeds are good
what about cherry what do cherry pits
have in them that are good for you
nothing
it has cyanide cyanide in the cherry pit
oh that's brian i bet you in his eyes i
bet his eyes went like this freaked out
a little bit and then i bet he did a
little story of a guy who had two of
them because he thought it was cool i
had rushed into the hospital i'm like
two should i have six
brian be careful man be careful i did i
cannot believe that actually had to come
out of my mouth i never thought a
million years i would have to say eat
some bread to soak up the cyanide i'm
shocked i had no idea
i'm usually really careful i'm shocked
sorry but i mean you do look healthy
right now i mean but yeah i mean you're
glowing not sure if it's the nuclear
waste in the cherries but
maybe it wasn't cherry pits maybe maybe
it was something else right
maybe maybe something good
yeah rock and roll
i can't believe that was your go-to
tomorrow tomorrow you're going to come
around with a whole lot of bumps and
stuff on
remember the guy from the fly yeah
yeah
kathy said you must have had a good
bowel movement that's probably why you
don't have any system
it's all gone
thank you
look two o'clock in the morning he's
like
oh
oh get to go go go go
oh man
stay away from the pits brian
hey i don't know if it's a guy thing or
what but
that those jokes never get old
yeah no they don't they don't you know
matter of fact boy i remember i remember
when i just i just laid on laying on the
floor in the bathroom i was like the
floor is cold
yeah i just gotta lay on the floor
oh my gracious
okay
cherry pit cherry pit smith yeah don't
do it don't do it that's what the p
stands for and
words of advice
don't do it
brian said
that's the pitch
okay tomorrow is our friday or thursday
quick week thank you so much
excuse me for tuning in have you ever
had
this in the sponsor have you ever had
clear splash
never heard it
yeah i don't like it because there's uh
stuff in it
a spartan
oh
aspartame yeah aspartame that's how you
say it yeah it's it gives me i like
never quit water.com better it gives me
headaches aspartame does give me
headaches i had no idea i started was
drinking i'm like oh it's sugar-free i
think that's my plan
i never get headaches
instead
ladies and gentlemen the reason why i
brought that up thank you very much miss
on-time duty somebody
is
never create water never create water
campaign helps clean your food better
and
well it helps clean it better than tap
water and it has over 100 uses
and makes seven different types of ph
waters you can use this water in your
house you can use it to drink you can
use it to cook with you can you there's
so many different ways that you can use
this
and they are a sponsor on our show
now how do you get it you go to
www.neverquitwater.com
and you will see a place where you put
your name and your email address now
don't look past this okay don't look
past this you see it we're gonna have
the uh uh and the guy in charge of this
on next week gonna have him and so on so
he can answer your questions and stuff
but don't look past this especially with
um the holiday season coming up you are
going to need
this in your house it may i mean and uh
it's better for you it's it's better for
your body and it's better for your
innards a whole lot better than uh these
the bottled waters and the tap water and
all that stuff and everything i'm
telling you it works and just think if
brian would have had one of these
machines instead of a blender he would
have never drank cyanide he would have
drank
alkaline water
and he'd be alive today
so you say save your life you've got to
never put water down
i must ask please hold up that water
bottle again were you drinking cherry
water
i mean it just goes so long it goes
i ain't holding up nothing i am not home
now
cherries are good for you
not not cherry pits
not the pits and a shout out to barb
barbara said uh i love the show great
show today thank you for watching barb
yeah cherries
love them there is nothing like just
take the pits out there's nothing like
putting a handful of cherries in a
smoothie it really changes the whole
thing
especially after a good workout it's
great for you not the pigs
you like cherries though
yeah cherries blacks berries
raspberries i'm not really into cherries
i like apples blues berries
i like apples a lot
frozen
throw them in there instead of ice do
you do you put grapes in the freezer
yeah
is leah from frozen
she's like laughing at us somehow
yeah like this evil laugh like we're
doing something wrong everybody get a
screenshot right now
oh
[Laughter]
that's a once-in-a-lifetime chance y'all
yeah yeah
or you know you can always watch the
show again and read and and fast forward
to it and get you
get a screenshot yo
all right we gotta go um
she she's probably gonna come back on
but um
she's not even there he's not even close
to coming up i know right we we uh we
will
be here tomorrow
uh tomorrow's again our friday your
thursday
friday or thursday uh
and we're gonna be closing out the week
make sure that you watch everything that
you can watch about what's happening
over there and um
and kabul and
uh one thing one thing i did want to end
the show with is
uh this covered nice covet 19 booster i
was watching
uh the cdc director and fauci come on
and talk about this booster it's
supposed to be offered by uh september
20th
there man they're gonna be putting
boosters and more boosters and boosters
on top of boosters until jesus comes
back and i mean
almost three billion
shots yeah do you realize the amount of
money these four angels of death
are going to make i was thinking about
that this morning i was like
i mean somebody is making money
somebody is making a whole lot of money
off of these shots that's a third of the
population of the world yeah yeah yeah
so
uh pfizer i mean if you got the pfizer
shot or the modern shot
uh
you
biden is expected to call for a third
covet shot for americans who were fully
vaccinated with a two-shot regimen
citing the threat from the highly
contagious delta virus the stellar delta
the announcement on wednesday is likely
to cover more than 155 million that's
that's close to half
of the country
so and and the fda has been weighing
whether adults who receive the j j
single shot will also need another
coordinate t-shirt all these shots
cocktails man it's cocktail cocktails um
so
cocktail yeah we're getting ready to
leave ladies and gentlemen we want y'all
to have a great
uh a great evening uh we'll see you
tomorrow uh and stay away from the
cherry pits
and um
one thing one thing we got to keep away
from brian is envelopes
don't lick them don't lick them i don't
i'll lick my finger and then i wipe it i
know we don't let go we don't want brian
sending any envelopes to anybody after
he has learned how to ground up those
cherry pits
[Music]
that